bodies were recovered from the water and
inside the wreck but Italian authorities
say over 200 people are not accounted
for most of those on board were from
Eritrea and Somalia they boarded the
ship in Libya close to the shore of
Lampedusa the ship's engine failed
passengers led a fire to call for help
labrie my testimony on the entire ship
caught fire everybody rushed to one side
to escape the flames capsizing the boat
hundreds ended up in the sea cuento
personas teapot it's the second time
this week that migrants have died in the
Mediterranean trying to get to Europe
and it's one of the worst such disasters
in recent years at the Vatican Pope
Francis expressed his sorrow non possono
ricordati con gran dia I can't mention
without great dismay the many victims of
this latest tragic shipwreck which
occurred off the coast of lamb producer
today ena the word that comes to mind is
disgrace it is a disgrace Italy's
Parliament said they're doing all they
can yes there is no miraculous solution
for stopping these tragedies from
occurring if there were we would be
doing it already we have saved hundreds
of lives many others have died of course
we must try even harder unquote early
buell human rights activists are calling
on Europe to change its immigration
policy Italy is usually the first port
of call for migrants but authorities say
lambda duza has to be considered the
frontier to Europe not just to Italy